- Find your center of balance, bro.
- [Toy] Ready!
- Hey, guy, you asked me
who I made on Overwatch.
(toy screaming)
I'm not gonna give you
(laughs), not gonna tell you.
I'm gonna make you wait for the footage.
- [Toy] We don't have all day!
I'm flying!
(toy crashing)
You won't get rid of me that easily!
(electronic music)
- Now you guys know my username.
As you can tell, I am currently plat
which is upsetting to me.
Okay.
- [Player] Oh, shit.
- Aggressive, I like it, Rein, I like it.
I'm not even against it,
I'm not even mad at that.
I'm healing you up, keep
swinging like a champ, baby.
Diva, you're low health,
Diva, you're low health.
Diva, you're low health!
Wait, Winston, wait wait wait,
I gotta heal you up, buddy, let's go.
Let's go, let's go, easy work, baby!
(weapons firing)
(characters grunting)
I got a pick.
Two picks.
- (Player] What, who's doing this?
Is it the real one or?
- I'm the real Doctor Mike, brother.
Long time, no see, Black Dog.
Did you learn left from right?
- [Player] (bleep) you!
(Mike and Black Dog laughing)
- You were messing with
our minds, I get it.
- [Player] No, their minds, right?
- They can't hear our chat,
bro, this isn't Call of Duty.
Where is this Widow?
(weapons firing)
- [Player] She's on the left.
- I got her, I got her, good call-out.
All right, Soldier's down.
(weapons firing)
Widow's down.
Zen's down.
Road Hog is the only one.
Use him for all charge
and keep pushing point.
Get three on point, get three on point.
All day, all day, every day.
You gotta love Overwatch!
I mean, it's frustrating
when you have a team member
that won't swap.
You're begging them to go Healer
or Tank or Shield Tank, whatever it is.
But if you get a team that's in sync,
even if you lose, I think
it's still fun to play.
Just 'cause there's so much teamwork,
deciding what Ults go first.
- [Player] Did you lose your Ult?
- No!
(weapons firing)
No, what a nupe!
I saved you!
I saved you, Black Dog!
- [Player] Thanks, but uh, yeah.
- Oh yeah, let's go!
Hahaha, sorry, Mercy.
Oh, wait, who sniped me?
(weapons firing)
(grunting)
Rein down.
(weapons firing)
(grunting)
RoadHog down.
That's right, baby.
Guys, I'm literally
fighting by myself here.
(Mike laughing)
- [Player] We're gamers.
- What?
Oh, great first pick, that's huge!
The thing about Overwatch
is that it's simple
yet incredibly complex.
It almost reminds me of chess,
even though I'm not a big chess player,
but this season I've been
playing Junkrat a lot
which I know may surprise you.
In real life, I'm
constantly healing people,
so I come home, I wanna do some damage.
(weapons firing)
That's what I do, baby boo!
That's what I do.
Go left, go left, go left.
Or not, wow, okay.
My mic was muted this
whole time, I'm a nupe.
Yo, Reaper, we really need
you to pick it up, baby!
Come on!
Our Reaper went off second tank
and now has been just playing trash bag.
I tried, I tried so hard.
All right, that was a tough loss.
That's the thing about this game.
Like, I got up to 3,100.
I know it's not amazing,
but, and then like in two
days, I drop like 300 SR.
That's so, this game is stressful.
That's why I said on Surgeon Simulator.
This is the most frustrating
thing I've ever played.
And I play Overwatch.
But it's that good kind of stress that,
when you overcome it, you feel good.
Mr. Pancake.
Yo, Mr. Pancake, didn't
I just play with you?
No, okay.
Guess we're not on talking terms.
I'm gonna break everything in this room.
Why is, is that recycling from the future?
- [Game Character] Get ready for a show!
- Oopsie daisy, double kill!
All right, I'm gonna set up on top here
and pressure them.
(wepaons firing)
(grinting)
Oh, how did this Zen get up here?
I have a long run, guys.
I'm gonna be there in a few minutes.
(weapons firing)
Oh, I got slept.
Soldier up top, he's, he's
putting a lot of damage.
Good job, Genji.
(weapons firing)
That's what we do,
baby, that's what we do.
Keep it simple, KIS.
Someone called me, but
they obviously didn't know
I was playing Overwatch.
(Mike hiccupping)
Easy pickings, easy pickings, boys.
How did he snipe me?
That was really embarrassing.
Hate playing against decent Widows.
(weapons firing)
(grunting)
Oh, that's so frustrating!
Let's do a pro switch right now.
(weapons firing)
That's what I'm talking about, pro switch!
(action music)
Oh my God!
What a noob, that I am.
I didn't see her from above me.
Gaming isn't my strong suit,
but reacting to popular medical TV shows?
Now that's my thing.
So, click here for a full playlist.
Stay happy, and healthy!
But click the playlist.